of course the big story these days
probably bigger than the presidential
election is the financial crisis we read
about this every day and don't boo the
financial crisis that'll show that
crisis that's what we need to be doing
all this time enough with our economic
plans that choice should boo it that's
what should happen no here's what we
keep reading the Fed the federal
government keeps injecting money into
the economy every time you read about a
solution it's there injecting more money
into the economy and they say they have
to do it to jumpstart the economy well I
was thinking why are we letting the
government do all of this why are we
sitting around waiting for the
government to solve this problem don't
you think as citizens it's our duty to
do the same thing get some money into
the economy so I had this idea today I
had this idea that maybe I should spend
some money alright I have a wad of cash
here I have the one of cash please this
is $400
[Applause]
[Music]
that's $400 in singles okay I was gonna
go to a strip club just how I usually go
I got 400 in singles here this was we
were saving this for the interns pizza
party but screw them right what have
they ever done for me except work for
free now there are a bunch of stores
downstairs in the lobby here at 30 rock
that I think could use the money all
right
and I thought I could spend the 400
downstairs and here's how it's a win-win
I thought I could buy something for the
entire studio audience here
I need you know because I think it's 200
people in the audience that's a lot of
stuff to carry I thought I should get
someone to help me so I'm gonna go look
around and see if we can find somebody
here who will help me nice try but the
way they're playing against the Rays I
can't take you about this guy right here
this guy wants to do it stand up sir
come on out here what is your name sir
Jason okay where you from Jason
Pennsylvania okay I like what you're
wearing - it's got a Western theme and
you're also look at that those are some
baggy flares you got going on there
I wasn't sure you were wearing shoes
will you come with me and help me get
something for the audience all right
let's do it
nice nice alright we're going this way
and no is it raise it what you said your
name is Jason it's Steve right okay OTO
here's what we're gonna do
Jason you're gonna come downstairs with
me hello huh let's tip the pages on the
way hello little something for you as
well just the girl okay here we go let's
go downstairs now we're gonna get some
stuff for the whole studio audience okay
is it weird for you to be alone in an
elevator with me can you smell me right
now there's a little camera right there
wave to the people in the audience here
you go anything hear me just come with
me hi everybody how are you good to see
ya huh a little something for you yeah
right this way folks good to see ya how
are you right this way
it's bill right chocolate shop look at
this la maison du Chocolat audience like
chocolate I bet you the audience likes
chocolate they like chocolate I hear
screaming let's go hello how are you
oh wow these are free samples could I
have 200 trays of free samples please
these people you know what these are
free here help yourself Jason hmm that's
good tell me about this what is this
this is free 20 bucks is how much I've
got four hundred dollars here what is
this how much is this fifteen dollars
what are you talking about fifteen
dollars for this little box of
chocolates see the box little beautiful
box you facebooking people box these
people want chocolate we gotta get the
economy going this is a lot of money
hands smell that dough all right what do
you say come on fifteen dollars really
someone do the math what's 200 times $15
anybody what's wrong with you people
3,500 hi hi how are you good to see you
sir Brian Late Night with Conan O'Brien
it's my pal Jason receive yeah all right
and how about this how much for this cup
of hot chocolate eight dollars for a cup
of hot chocolate in this economy are you
out of your mind
hi how are you doing good to see you
which is selling their hazelnut how much
for one of those a dollar eighty for
this okay a dollar eighty there you put
that back no one's gonna notice just
push it up a little bit just push it up
and just put it right back in there good
to see you sir what's this brush for
shine the chocolate okay very nice it
soon
where's my pal
$1 84 chocolate that's kind of crazy
where do you live where you from
wilkes-barre would you get away with a
dollar 84 chocolate and wilkes-barre
would that even work
yeah that's insane
hold on one second
there's a nice little store down here
that might be good they've got look at
this a lot of souvenirs and stuff
audience likes souvenirs
hi how are you good to see you excuse us
sorry hi cameras look people are running
a lot of illegal immigrants trust me if
you don't want to be on camera stay out
of the way if you're wanted for any
crime stay out of the way all right what
do we have here these are all buttons
mugs how much for this mug 1099 what is
your name
Marissa nice to meet you my pal Jason
right here let's see what kind of things
do you have here oh you have look at
this I Love New York pajamas yeah
Jason do me a favor try this on see if
it's the kind of thing they would like
in the audience can you put that on fast
is it okay if my friend tries this on
that's all right you sure okay you have
nice stuff here look at that they have
picture frames cabs look at that those
Statue of Liberty how much for this
Statue of Liberty okay 1499 two hundred
people that's over $65,000 what do you
think that looks good what is this thing
[Applause]
we might need a changing room in case he
wants to try other things let's what
soups good
[Applause]
displaying Oh how much for a little mr.
Matt little mr. Matt guy how much is
that how much 10 19 1099 for the little
Messer mett guy here that's about 10
bucks right there
[Applause]
go this way hello everybody how are you
hi good to see you how you doing how are
you for you listen can you buy a bounce
[Applause]
so Jason we're outside in New York I'm
gonna have Jason hold the money so I
don't get mugged this is what you don't
do in New York hold it up high and go yo
I've got money say no one mug me I've
got money
[Music]
[Music]
hey no a bakery best cupcakes in the
world let's go get hey audience like
cupcakes oh it smells good in here tell
the audience how good it smells no love
it smells amazing here we're gonna buy
some cupcakes here sir Tommy how much
for 200 cupcakes whatever you say
really I've got about 380 dollars left
they threw a lot of it away can we have
200 cupcakes from my audience yes
[Applause]
tonight folks we're gonna get cupcakes
for the audience right everybody
so tonight the new movie sitting under
Bill Murray's on the show
I mean you've done W hole agrees on the
show that's a funny you look at Suellen
Montaigne is on the show
one more show coming up stick around
we'll be right back
[Music]